gute Nachrichten für kleine Youtuber
jetzt könnt ihr Youtube Star werden es
gibt ein einmaliges Programm von YouTube
und zwar heißt es next up 25 Youtuber
aus Europa die nicht mehr als 50.000
abonnenten haben werden ausgewählt um
zum einen 20.000 € einzustecken um Ihr
Projekt weiter nach vorne zu bringen und
an einem creators Camp in London
teilzunehmen wo ihnen Youtube Cracks
noch den ein oder anderen Tipp geben wie
Sie Ihre Videos noch erfolgreicher
machen können für das ganze gibt's einen
eigenen Kanal
youtube.com/nexup hier unten verlinkt im
Video da drauf gehen da sind alle
Bedingungen eine muss ich schon mal
vorher sagen ihr müsst Partner sein das
heißt entweder seid das schon oder haut
richtig rein lasst euch was einfallen
das geht ja relativ flott wenn man die
Bedingung erfüllt des Partnerprogramms
ich drück auf jeden Fall für alle die
schon Partner sind Partner werden wollen
aber die an nextup teilnehmen die Daumen
und ansonsten guckt mal bei klickum
Spezial rein da stellen wir ja den einen
oder anderen kleinen Youtuber vor da
könnt ihr auch mal gucken was es da so
gibt ja also Daumen habe ich glaube ich
schon gedrückt ich würde sagen dann ist
alles gesagt und haut
rein